- Now the discussion
is that we've had this,
the greatest insurrection
since the Civil War,
may be greater
than the Civil War,
was this January 6th thing,
according to these people.
So now they have to have
a new sort of Patriot Act.
They're gonna have a new
domestic terrorism, you know,
catch all that they're
gonna go after us.
But I tell people who
think that would be great.
I tell them to be
careful what you wish for
because the definition
of what they call an
insurrectionist may well be
that you teach your kids at home
that you voted for Donald Trump
or you went to a Trump rally.
It could be that you
believe in being left alone.
You believe in the
second amendment.
Somehow you may own a gun.
God forbid that be
in California, but
you may own a gun
and if so, you may well
be an insurrectionist
and then they can look
at all of your stuff
and see if they can find you
or trap you into a crime.
(bright upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is an ophthalmologist,
the Senator from the
great State of Kentucky
and a man who celebrates
Festivus every year.
Senator Rand Paul, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks Dave,
thanks for having me.
- I was hoping you were
gonna have your Festivus pole
with you, but I guess it's
just a seasonal thing for you?
- If you show up on Festivus,
we will do some wrestling,
so we'd be prepared.
- All right, so you
are in DC, I am in LA,
who's worse off right now?
- Well, we have razor wire
that surrounds our campus now.
So the likes of you and
any other American citizen
that wants to visit their
Capitol, you're not welcome here
because you gotta
call up Nancy Pelosi,
she's gotta come out
to the fence to get you
to bring you in.
And so there's no tourism in DC.
There are no government workers
and you wanna see
some sad people,
there's a local restaurant
we go to call The Dubliner,
around the corner and
it's owned by a family.
They're wonderful people.
They've no customers,
nobody works anymore.
The whole, all DC is
like a vacant city
and now we've got razor wire
surrounding the Capitol.
So it's really the
most uninviting scene
you'll ever see.
- Yeah, have you made any
headway figuring out, you know,
I know they extended
it I suppose this
emergency situation,
quote unquote
emergency situation
for two months or something.
Have you made any
headway finding out like,
what do they really think
is going on at this point?
- Well, it's a secret,
it's top secret
but if I tell you,
you won't tell anyone.
- I, no, I won't, I won't.
And we're not even
gonna record this thing.
- Yeah, it's about optics.
And on January 6th, they weren't
prepared for a big crowd.
And in all likelihood
that was Nancy Pelosi
making bad decisions about
being prepared for the crowd.
And so what is she doing now?
She's overcompensating.
So they were under-prepared
and now they're over-prepared.
There hasn't been,
there's not a protestor
within 100 miles of DC.
In fact, if you
come shopping in DC,
Bank of America will give up
your credit card information
to the feds so they can search
your computer and decide
whether or not you're an
insurrectionist or not.
So, I asked the FBI about this
and they won't respond to us.
We've asked them in writing.
Did they demand these
records from Bank of America?
Did Bank of America just
volunteer to be America's,
you know, spy for your
credit card system
but to look at everybody's
shopping habits
and decide that then
we'll investigate you
if you were shopping on January
6th in DC, is a (indistinct)
to the idea that the fourth
amendment means anything.
- How fearful are you that all
of the ideas that
you've cared about
for your whole career, the
ideas that your dad put forth,
the ideas that the founders
put forth about freedom
and liberty and all of those
things that they really feel
like they're sort of coming
to the end right now?
- Well, you know, the Democrats
have admitted this before,
you remember Emanuel
saying back when,
no crisis go to waste, this
is a crisis once again,
we had a crisis of
911, but guess what,
the Patriot Act was written
in the 1990s, put on a shelf
and they waited until they
finally got a disaster,
a real disaster,
but they had 911.
They brought it out, but it
was about people control.
And it was about
control of ideology.
Now the discussion is
that we've had this,
the greatest insurrection
since the Civil War,
may be greater
than the Civil War,
was this January 6th thing,
according to these people.
So now they have to have
a new sort of Patriot Act.
They got to have a new
domestic terrorism, you know,
catch all that, they're
gonna go after us.
But I tell people who
think that would be great.
I tell them to be
careful what you wish for
because the definition of what
they call an insurrectionist
may well be that you teach your
kids at home, that you voted
for Donald Trump, or you
went to a Trump rally.
It could be that you believe
in, you know, being left alone.
You believe in the
second amendment.
Somehow you may own a gun.
God forbid that be
in California, but
you may own a gun
and if so, you may well
be an insurrectionist
and then they can look
at all of your stuff
and see if they can find you
or trap you into a crime.
This is coming, it's become
a bizarre place in DC.
It's a military camp and
essentially we now have people
who have receded
into their own camps.
And I fear what's coming really
because of how radical
the left wing has become.
And they're not willing
to take no for an answer.
So it used to be, they said,
well, we don't have 60 votes
in the Senate, so we won't
get everything we want.
Now they're gonna, they say,
they're gonna hold
off on the filibuster.
My prediction is within
six months, they'll get rid
of the filibuster and by
brute force, they'll ram
through their entire agenda,
which is farther to the left
than most people in America
could really imagine.
- Okay, so the million dollar
question, I'm with you,
I think everyone that
is sensible is worried
about all of this stuff.
Do you think Joe Biden is in
charge of the Democratic party?
- Joe, Joe, who's that?
Who are you talking about?
- Joe, the guy
gets up there and,
- (indistinct) the figurehead
over at the White House, yeah.
No, I think it's a mixture.
No, do I think he's actually
the president and in charge?
Yes, but what I would say
is that there's a great deal
of influence coming from the
left wing of his partying.
I don't think he has
maybe the fortitude
he may have had 15 years
ago to stick with positions
that he might disagree with
the left wing (indistinct).
So I think that largely policy
will come from the left side.
The energy of the
Democrat party is coming
from the socialist crowd,
coming from the woke crowd.
And so I think they will dictate
most of what goes on there.
And that's what we're
gonna see over time.
But I don't think you're gonna
get a moderate president.
It's sort of like the
idea of, you know,
whether or not they could
give our kids, you know,
cross gender hormones
without our permission.
That's not a moderate position.
That is a far out
extreme position.
Even if you're a
Democrat, most Democrats,
if you talk to them would say,
the children really
shouldn't be allowed
to have surgical procedures
without their
parents' permission.
They're arguing that even
if their parents say no,
the government's allowed to
intervene to say, yeah, so,
now this isn't a moderate
crowd or a middle-class woke.
I mean, this is really the
woke crowd you're gonna see.
- Yeah, so to that
point, you got into it
with Rachel Levine who, what's
the position she was going
for, is it deputy
health secretary?
- Yeah, she'll be the assistant
and my question to her
was basically that.
If a child says they wanna take,
change their sexual appearance
and the parents say no
would the government intervene
to involve themselves
and side with the child?
And the answer basically coming
from these people is yes.
The other answer that comes
from them, kids between the ages
of three and 10 go to
these clinics or kids go to
but 10% of the kids are between
the ages of three and 10.
When they get there,
do you think anybody's
counseling them against this?
- [Dave] Right.
- No, everybody there
has already either
undergone the
procedure themselves
or is an activist
for this decision.
And they, there is no
counterpoint there.
So the kids are
given reassurance
and told this is a great thing.
And you need surgery and
you need these hormones.
And if your parents say, no,
we're not gonna tell them.
You even have schools that
used to not give a kid
a Tylenol are willing
to give these kind
of powerful hormones that
have life altering changes
to the body, willing
to give these to kids
without telling the parents.
That is alarming and
I think most parents
who think through this
would be alarmed about this.
- Yeah, I agree, obviously,
and I think most parents do.
They just seem to be
afraid to speak up
but I know you're
crunched on time.
So, let's just do four questions
like two or three
minutes each and,
'cause you have a couple
of bills coming that I
think are really interesting
but first real quick
on the lockdowns.
At this point, you know, I'm
still in a lockdown State
and city here, California,
LA, what's your position
basically at this point now
that States are
slowly opening up?
- I think if you
wanna go out and eat,
you should become better
friends with Governor Newsom.
He apparently is allowed
to go out to eat.
And apparently it's
pretty good food.
- Oh, yeah, French
(indistinct) ain't bad.
- (indistinct) for dinner,
some of the best wine in Napa.
So, you just need
better friends Dave
when you need (indistinct)
or you can come
visit another State.
It is night and day as
you travel the country.
If you go to Florida, which
has a lower death rate
than California or New York
or New Jersey, it's wide open.
You hardly see anybody
wearing a mask.
You still have people
freaking out saying,
I saw a person at the beach.
I saw someone at the beach and
they didn't have a mask on.
Oh my God, what's gonna happen.
But they don't
chase down surfers
like they do in California.
You know, they don't
send the coast guard
after someone on a paddle board
but there really is a
difference between the States.
And I think that it's
getting to the point though
where the statistics are
so overwhelmingly good
that this disease is leaving us.
They're gonna be hard pressed
to really make up some sort
of narrative that we have
to go on, but they will,
you know, Fauci is still
saying wear mask into 2022.
But if you look at the
daily incidents of disease,
it's a straight downward line
and I'm thankful for that.
And I think it's a combination
of both natural immunity
and the vaccine that's
bringing it down.
The deaths are coming
down and, you know,
there was a doctrine on
"The Wall Street Journal"
about two weeks ago
from Johns Hopkins.
And he's predicting by the end
of April, this could be gone.
Nobody knows for certain,
but I would take his counsel
in mind as much or more
than Fauci who says, oh,
there's gonna be another
worldwide, you know,
surge and it's all but over
and we're gonna
have to, you know,
the planet will be uninhabitable
in another 10 years.
These doomsday
people, really we need
to hear countervailing
opinions, that's for sure.
- Senator are you saying that
I might be able to celebrate
with my family before July 4th?
I might be able to see my
parents before independence day?
- As long as there's two
or three of you and no more
and you have to put it on Zoom
so Dr. Fauci can
watch your celebration
and make sure you only do the,
what are the sticks
that light up?
Don't do any,
- Oh, sparklers, no sparklers.
- Sparklers only, sparklers only
but no explosive
fireworks for you.
- In weird sense though, as
you've seen the States do
such wildly
different procedures,
does that prove that
federalism kinda does work?
I mean, I know you don't
want the federal government
telling everyone what to do,
but as you've seen just Florida
do what's right for Florida
and then the people
that are stuck
in Cali are just stuck in Cali.
Like it kind of is how
the system's supposed
to work, right?
- Well, I think the
interesting thing is,
is you have all these
different sets of data
because you have 50 States
doing 50 different policies
but we also had hundreds
of different governments
around the world doing
different policies.
And if someone will
objectively look at this,
we have more data
on this disease
than anything we've ever
had in the history of man.
But the one thing that is
for certain is the
highest death rate
for any governmental unit
is New York and New Jersey.
So they were probably the
most restrictive, you know,
with lockdowns but they
have the highest death rate.
Sweden did most things
voluntarily and has one
of the lower death rates.
In the end, the death rates
all sort of coalesced.
And I think in the end,
the argument could be made
that man had very little effect
on the trajectory of
this until the vaccine.
And even the vaccine right now,
I think it is definitely
helping, but I think
that a huge incidence
of disease in December
and January also the natural
immunity is a big part
of this disease coming down.
So it's natural immunity
plus, you know, the vaccine
that's really doing a trick.
I'm getting, the question I get
in the hall four
times a day now is,
are you gonna take the vaccine?
Are you gonna take the vaccine?
And I'm pro-vaccine,
I'm for people who are
at high risk taking the
vaccine, but I tell them,
look 30 million people
in America have had the
disease like myself.
There's maybe a handful, and
some of these are questionable.
There may be a handful of
people who got it twice,
but guess what, there's
zero hospitalizations
from anybody getting it the
second time and zero deaths.
And so like,
can we not just let somebody
else have the vaccine?
You know, I'm perfectly content.
I've had it.
Do you have to harass me
every day saying I need
to be vaccinated 'cause Dr.
Fauci wants me to vaccinate him
but realize that's another
noble lie on his part.
He only wants me vaccinated
as an example, as a model, he
knows it's of no value to me.
And if he were in private,
he would admit as much.
But he's once again lying to us,
telling us all the
people who've had it,
you have to take it again
because it's about examples,
it's about conformity,
and it's about submission, has
nothing to do with science.
- What would you say
to the average say healthy
44-year-old who has not had it?
Should they be going to get the
vaccine once it's available?
- You're saying like
a healthy 44-year-old
or someone like you?
- Yeah, well, in effect,
you know, someone, yeah,
someone like me, well,
just a relatively healthy,
relatively young person.
- For the sake of
argument, we'll say
that you both of
those, relatively young
and relatively healthy,
we'll stipulate to that.
Anyway, I think
you weigh the risk
and I don't wanna be
too much, you know,
trying to enforce my
opinion on a 44-year-old.
If you wanna make the
decision, you base it
on the rate of death
for your age group
and your body type versus
the risks of the vaccine.
So, for example, right
now, if I were in Europe
and you told me I could
get the AstraZeneca vaccine
or be 44-year-old and healthy,
I'd stay the hell away from
the AstraZeneca vaccine.
It sounds like there's
enough complications.
There was a lot of cities got,
a lot of countries
going away from it.
And here's the other
question for our country
and people don't
wanna bring this up
'cause it has to
do with the truth
and you'd have to
think through it.
I believe the AstraZeneca
is a adenovirus.
I think Johnson and
Johnson is an adenovirus.
So I would ask a question
before I took the Johnson
and Johnson in our country,
how is it different than
the AstraZeneca vaccine
and how is it the same?
Because I don't know if
we've had enough people yet.
Are we gonna have
the same problem
with the Johnson and Johnson?
I'm sure they'll be
calling me after this.
I don't know if it's true,
but I think it's worth,
can somebody at least
ask the question?
The other ones, the MRNA
vaccines, Moderna and Pfizer.
Now we've had millions
of people take them.
There are some complications
but if you're over
80, without question,
it's much better to take
the vaccine than not.
If you're over 70, in
all likelihood, yes.
With each successive decade
down, it becomes more,
a more marginal benefit.
The other thing that's
happening is the disease
is coming down
dramatically right now
from both natural
immunity and the vaccine.
You know, if you're unsure,
wait a month and
make a decision.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You know, Dr. Fauci will
be mad at me for saying that
but in a free country,
it's your decision to make
and there isn't an
absolute right or wrong.
You know, I, for myself,
I've already had it.
I'm not taking it again.
If you tell me that in the
next two months that a lot
of people that had it start
dying, I probably reevaluate.
I'm not gonna be adamant
that I'm not taking it
but right now there's
nobody who's died
from a second infection
and I know of nobody
who's been hospitalized
from a second infection.
So I'm a little cautious with
wanting to get re-vaccinated
since I've already
been vaccinated the
old fashioned way.
- Yeah, it's just incredible
because you're giving
me a much more robust
and honest assessment
than anything
that we're hearing out
of Fauci but all right,
I just wanna talk quickly
about two bills that
you've introduced
because I'm not a big fan of
bills, but every now and again,
something comes in to
actually restrict the power
of the government
over the people.
Talk to me about The REINS Act.
- The REINS Act says that
when unelected bureaucrats
wanna write a regulation
that would injure the economy
or cost the economy
over 100 million dollars
that lo and behold, they
shouldn't be allowed to do it
without Congress approving
of that regulation.
This is one of the most
amazing things that I learned
when I got here is that
most of the onerous,
costly, expensive
regulations are not written
by your legislators, they're
written by bureaucrats.
The legislators write
a survey or a sort
of a shell of a bill that
lets the regulators write
all the teeth of
the regulations.
Like under Obamacare,
there were 1500 references
to the secretary of health
shall decide at a later date.
So really Obamacare was written
by the secretary of health.
So same way with these.
So under The REINS
Act if it passed,
these major regulations
would be created
by bureaucrats but sent back
to the House to be voted on.
To my mind, this is one of the
best performs it's out there
for trying to restrain
big government.
So far we have, let me
think, oh, zero co-sponsors
from the Democrat side,
probably 20 or 30 Republicans.
We may have had one vote
in the past and we get most
of the Republicans on board
and almost no Democrats.
At one time, Mansion was
a co-sponsor of this.
I don't know if
he'd vote for it now
but at one time he
was a co-sponsor.
I don't think we have him
on it anymore, but it shows
that there really is a
difference between the parties.
It doesn't mean all Republicans
are good, it doesn't mean
that no Democrats are
any good on regulation.
- So when you introduce a
bill like that and you know
it's not gonna get
any bipartisan support
and struggle with your,
within your own party.
Are you doing it more just
because you want people
to understand these ideas?
I mean, you want people to,
at least hear about
some of this stuff.
- Well, because if it passed,
this is how it would
fix our government.
I think people want
to have solutions.
The other thing is that
perhaps somebody running
for Senate in Arizona decides,
well, it's a great idea
and I'm gonna run my
campaign on this issue.
That regulations should have
to be approved by Congress.
I think it's something that
could be a motivating force
for people in election cycles.
It's the same reason
I oppose, you know,
sending stimuluses
to dead people,
even though I know
everybody up here is for it
but I'm not really for
sending stimulus checks,
even though I'm not gonna win,
I'm not for sending stimulus
checks to dead people.
Last summer, over a million
dead people got stimulus checks
to the tune of over
a billion dollars.
So I introduced
legislation to fix it.
It passed by unanimous consent
but a Democrat
Senator came running
to the floor and said, no, I
object, but he was too late.
And so it got passed and
then it went to the House
but he was mad 'cause we
passed it over his objection.
So he got his buddies
in the House to stop it.
And then when they
finally did get around to,
they said, well, we're
really kind of for this.
We kind of, maybe they do,
but some dead people's
relatives could use this money.
And so they did pass
it, but they said,
we will only end the process
of sending checks to dead
people in three years.
So this is how ineffective
your government is.
They can't even immediately
end sending checks
to dead people, takes
them three years
to unravel the complexity of
mailing checks to dead people.
- I believe this is
what we call the swamp.
All right, the other
piece that you're trying
to get pass is the
National Right to Work Act.
- Yeah, I think that
you shouldn't be fired
for the choice of whether
they join a union or not.
It should be up to you
and we shouldn't sort of
have federal legislation
that encourages businesses
to fire people who say, ah,
I just decided, you
know, I don't like,
let's say you're pro-life
and you don't want all the
money go into, you know,
planned parenthood
or something you say,
I don't wanna send
money to my union
'cause it sends money to
the Democrats for this.
And so I think that
should be your choice.
So this National
Right to Work law
doesn't really add new law.
You should like this.
All it does is take away law.
So some of the labor law
from the '30s and '40s
mandated this protectionism
for unions and all it
does is strip that away.
It's not anti-union.
In fact, I think there are
times when the smaller players
should be allowed to come
together to use their leverage
to strike a better deal,
whether it's wages
or prices, frankly.
So I'm for like
consumers forming a union
or a co-op to negotiate
with big insurance
and big tech and everybody else.
I think there are ways
that we could get the consumer
to have more leverage.
So I'm not against
the idea of union,
of collectively trying to gather
to (indistinct) for something
but I think you
should have a choice.
- How has basically one
of the few people
that actually cares
about limited government and all
of the principles
that I'm constantly
espousing on the show,
do you just not go crazy while
working for the government?
Like, especially now as it's
gotten so out of control.
Like truly, how do you just
like manage to have a smile
on your face and be
funny and fun and happy
and the rest of it while
in the midst of that thing?
- Well, you know, when a
golfer gets the shanks,
he has to get a
sports psychologist.
I have a couple of sports
psychologists on the payroll.
They follow me around
and what we've also decided
to do is go with the science,
Dave, and I can't believe
you don't do this.
Here's what the
science tells you.
- Tell me please.
- The National Science
Foundation says
that if you will take
a picture, a selfie
of yourself smiling
and look at it later in the
day, you'll be a happier person.
And so that's what the
science says, Dave.
And if you will do that
and not get on Twitter
but look at selfies
of yourself smiling,
you'll be a much happier person
and don't talk politics either.
You gotta give up
on talking politics.
- That's the most sensible
thing I've heard anyone
in politics say in a long time.
Senator Rand Paul, I
appreciate the time.
- All right, thanks Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.